Maze Runner the death cure is the third
and final film in this franchise and
once again was directed by Wes ball of
stars Dylan O'Brien as Thomas who finds
himself in a climactic battle against an
evil corporation trying to find a cure
for this terrible disease known as the
flare when it comes to the Maze Runner
movies I think out of all young adult
adaptations we've seen of recent years
this has probably been one of the most
consistently fine franchises there isn't
an awful entry in my opinion and it's
considerably better than other young
adult franchises we've seen like Mortal
Instruments or Twilight's this film
franchise actually has some merit to it
because it has great talented people
behind the camera and in front of the
camera with death cure Dylan O'Brien
continues to impress me he's an actor I
would love to see in a great film I
think he has so much potential
he was very seriously injured during the
making of this movie doing a stunt and
it was life-threatening and the whole
production had to shut down which push
back the release of this film
considerably he dedicates himself quite
a bit to his roles and I would really
like to see him be given a better
opportunity clearly as an actor when you
see a franchise like this or his recent
film American assassin that had Michael
Keaton in it you jump at that chance but
he has yet to be involved in a truly
great film and I think that he has the
potential to do something really special
and well the death cure certainly is not
a fantastic film it basically falls into
the same weaknesses of the first two the
first film is well directed with great
action the second film is well directed
with great action the third film is also
well directed with great action but they
all have a story that feels stretched
very thin particularly this film because
it's very long and that's an easy
complaint it's very easy to sit down and
say this film is too long and that's why
it's not good I wouldn't even say that
death cure is not good there's plenty to
like in this movie and it's certainly
better than I expected going in it's
just that it takes quite a bit of time
to tell a very simple story because in
the long run this movie is actually not
so much about the Cure that's certainly
a major
elements I mean it's in the title this
evil corporation is trying to find a
cure to this virus that basically turns
people into walking zombies but in the
end it comes off kind of like a subplot
where the actual storyline is Thomas and
his friends searching for their buddy
who's been imprisoned and they spend
pretty much the entire movie doing it
gratefully there's a lot of really well
directed action scenes along the way and
good enough performance is to make me
feel somewhat invested but for a third
film and a franchise it didn't feel as
climactic as I wanted it to Dylan
O'Brien is very good but his character
Thomas isn't really given that weighty
material you expect to see in the final
film of a big franchise for a hero's
journey over a three film arc it has to
feel like they've truly changed and yeah
he has certainly changed from that
awkward kid who came up from the
elevator in the first film but by now
he's basically an action hero and he
spends most of the film being an action
hero but the things that really should
have made him change and evolve as a
character feel almost like background
elements at times a past relationship
and a friendship that I must say was
actually really touching and one of the
best elements of this film beyond the
fact that Wes ball has shown himself to
be a pretty good director with these
films especially with helming convincing
and exciting action sequences I must
commend him for one specific reason he
made his trilogy how many times with
these y-a adaptations as a director come
in made the first film got famous got
known and then went on to do other
projects it always happens with almost
every single major why a adaptation very
rarely does a director who comes on stay
with the franchise Wes ball stayed with
it he made all three and he committed to
it and you can tell that he really tried
to make these films as good as they
could be but it's unfortunate for this
film that the previous two didn't really
invest me all that much so I can't
really blame this film for the fact that
I walked in not really caring because
the previous two are at fault for that
this film tries its hardest to invest me
once again and while the action
sequences are certainly pretty exciting
and the production quality is actually a
lot higher than I expected it to be in
the end the
story just wasn't all there for myself
I'm gonna give Maze Runner the death
cure a C+ that's the same grade I've
given all three so at the very least I
can say this series has been consistent
it's just that it's been consistently
fine it could be better and it could be
a lot worse guys thank you so much as
always for watching if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]